I
in giving expression to this moment of
its self-conscious downfall as the
result of his experience it reveals
itself to be this inner perversion of
itself to be a deranged consciousness
which finds that it's essential being is
immediately non-essential its reality
immediately an unreality the derangement
cannot be taken to mean that in general
something devoid of essence is regarded
as essential something unreal is real so
that what for one person is essential or
real would not be so for another and
that the consciousness of reality and
unreality or with sensuality and
unessential ax t would thus fall apart
if something is in fact real and
essential for consciousness in general
but is not so for me that in the
consciousness of its nothingness I have
at the same time since I am
consciousness in general the
consciousness of its reality and since
they are both fixed in my consciousness
this is a unity which is madness in
general but in this state only an object
is deranged for consciousness not
consciousness is such within and for
itself but in the outcome of experience
which here has come to view
consciousness in its law is aware of
being itself this reality and at the
same time since this very same
essentiality the same reality is
alienated from it qua it is quad
self-consciousness qua absolute reality
aware of its own unreality in other
words it holds the two sides in their
contradiction to be immediately it's
essential being which is thus in its
almost being distraught
in paragraph 376 we finally come to the
second part of the title of this section
the frenzy of self-conceit and what
Hagel is going to talk about here
ultimately is going to be madness in
general vons in an alga minun a little
bit of a play on words there because
it's the allgemeine of the universal
that we've been worried about and trying
to realize and then losing our self in
and all of that so we saw that in the
last paragraph we had a sort of conflict
between to universals as well and it was
a conflict that could not be reconciled
overcome avoided instead what happens is
self-consciousness is overcome so in its
experience that's our far own and this
is a great play on words to in a certain
respect to it i mean experience so far
hung right fahren is is this word that's
used for for traveling to a certain
extent I mean there's other words as
well but there's this notion that we
talk about the path of experience and
that's what has been happening with the
law of the heart you don't know where
it's going to go until you actually step
out and start going somewhere start
acting what this led to is a
self-conscious downfall of the boost
untergang in the german and so how does
this actually take place so we have self
consciousness which is a shape or
gestalt all right the shape that is that
of the law of the heart and what Hagel
says is in giving expression to this
moment of its self conscious downfall as
the results of experience it reveals
itself to be this inner perversion of
itself for Carol don't think perversion
in a sexual sense just think in terms of
a you know being
whipped it up I mean that that's the
original sense that we get perversion
from pair of deer today you know sort of
twist it aside bound up on itself and
care Hong has has that original sense as
well so think of a consciousness that
can't go straight can't go where it
wants to go and then we have derangement
that he's going to talk about phil rook
tight this harkens back to the zero kite
it's a root of the you know being
distraught of the last paragraph when
consciousness uncovered this
contradiction and realize that it
couldn't get past this contradiction now
we have an intensification of that
derangement and this is what's going to
lead to the frenzy of self-conceit so he
says to be a deranged consciousness how
is it deranged now here is where Hagel
gives us a depiction of what it is to be
deranged what it is to be affected in
this way that really gets to the heart
of of something and he's going to say
look this is in every case of being
mistaken or even being insane this is
the cases where there's like a tragic
conflict going on and you couldn't help
but but go crazy as a result of it so
what is this like you notice that on
this side we have the self-consciousness
the law of the heart right and then we
on this side we have the the universal
the order whatever it is that we're
talking about and self-consciousness
encompasses both of them what
self-consciousness took to be essential
the law of the heart its own being for
itself its own pleasure turns out to be
non-essential what it took to be reality
it finds to be unreality so he says it
finds its essential being is immediately
non-essential its reality immediately
and
reality now here's where Hagel clarifies
something for us as shows us this is not
just somebody like going off the rails
and having a momentary lapse he says
this derangement cannot be taken to mean
that in general something devoid of
essence is regarded as essential
something unreal is real so that for one
person what is for one person as the
central real would not be so for another
and that the consciousness of reality
and unreality of essentiality a nun
essentiality would thus fall apart this
is why there's a derangement taking
place here the person who is deranged is
able to realize it as a matter of fact I
wouldn't even say is able to realize is
unable not to realize that they are
deranged the person who's totally crazy
who's you know seeing butterflies
everywhere that are talking to him and
telling him to drink bleach or something
like that you know reality it's not even
really in the picture I mean we might
quibble here I know people are going to
want to bring up lacan and psychosis and
but just forget about that for the
moment right we want to focus on this
instead this is a person who is
conscious that there is a reality that
ought to be what they are aligned with
and realizing and finds instead that
they're not this is a person for whom
the conflict goes all the way down and
they're painfully aware of it at least
for a little while the next paragraph
we're going to see something a bit
different so he says if something is in
fact real and essential for
consciousness in general but is not so
for me now I've got a problem says then
in the consciousness of its nothingness
I have at the same time why because i am
the consciousness in general
he says I he have the consciousness of
its reality so if I realize that I am
out of touch with what is genuinely real
and yet I can't bring myself in touch
with it I can't make myself conform to
it that's much more torturous than just
being out of whack with with reality
isn't it where there's nothing like that
an example of this would be the the
effective experience that some people
have in realizing that senility is
starting to take hold of them and they
have enough of an understanding to
realize that they're slipping but not
enough to change that somehow and they
think well it would be better in certain
respects if I wasn't even aware of this
but you know until I'm not aware of this
at least I am aware of this we can say
similar things about people's morbid
fears of death we can go on and on about
these sorts of things what makes what
drives the person crazy is that they
can't go completely crazy what makes it
so deranging is the fact that there is
essentially out there and they can't
find a way back into it and they had it
at one point so he goes on and he says
since these are both fixed in my
consciousness this is a unity which is
madness in general madness in the
universal all right so he goes on he
says this state is only an object in
this state only an object is deranged
for consciousness so it sounds like it's
getting a little bit better not
consciousness as such within and for
itself but the outcome of experience
which has come to view
consciousness in its law says is aware
of being itself this reality before it
had that experience before it tried out
the law of the heart tried applying it
it could have thought to itself yeah the
world is screwed up and it's a it's a
mass and I'm not crazy everybody else is
crazy or could have thought well maybe
I'm you know the romantic and I'm so
different than the rest of the world I'm
what Hagel will call later on the
beautiful soul and that you know world
out there is rational and I'm just not
rational in that way no it's now
consciousness is realized I'm all of
this stuff and yet I can't bring it
together successfully so he goes on and
he says at the same time since the very
same essentiality the same reality is
alienated from it it is quas
self-consciousness qua absolute reality
aware of its own unreality by being
aware of its own reality of being these
things of there being a conflict between
it it doesn't thereby escape there's
nothing soporific or tranquilizing and
realizing oh there's a conflict there
i'll just take note of that it goes all
the way down to the very depths of its
being so he says in other words it holds
the two sides in their contradiction to
be immediately it's essential being
which is thus in its own most being
distraught right so it takes both of the
sides of the contradiction in the
contradiction to be immediately it's
essential being which means that in its
very essence there is a contradiction a
virus Brook a you know saying something
against itself not being able to be on
the same page of itself a non
coincidence occurring within the
consciousness itself and this is a very
uncomfortable place to be
the heartthrob for the welfare of
humanity therefore it passes into the
ravings of an insane self-conceit into
the fury of consciousness to preserve
itself from destruction and it does this
by expelling from itself the perversion
which it is itself and by striving to
look at it and express it as something
else if therefore speaks of the
universal order as a perversion of the
law of the heart ended of its happiness
a perversion invented by fanatical
priests gluttonous despots and their
minions who compensate themselves for
their own degradation by degrading and
oppressing others a perversion which is
led to the nameless misery of deluded
humanity in this its derangement
consciousness declares individuality to
be the source of this derangement and
perversion but one that is alien and
accidental it is the heart of however
where the individuality of consciousness
that would be immediately Universal that
is itself the source of this derangement
and perversion and the outcome of its
action is merely that its consciousness
becomes aware of this contradiction for
the true is for it the law of the heart
something merely intended which unlike
the established order has not stood the
test of time but rather when thus tested
is overthrown this is law ought to have
reality the law that is for a quarry
allottee qua valid ordinance its own aim
and essential nature but reality that
very law qua valid ordinance is on the
contrary immediately for it something
which is not valid similarly its own
reality the heart itself is a particular
individual consciousness is for it its
essence but its purpose is to establish
that particular individuality as an
objective being thus it is rather itself
is not a particular individual that is
immediately for it its essence or its
purpose it has the form of a law hence
the form of a universality which is for
it its own consciousness this it's
notion becomes by its own action its
object thus the heart learns rather that
itself is not real and that it's reality
is an unreality it is therefore not an
accidental and alien individuality but
just this particular heart
which in all its aspects is in its own
self perverted and perverting
in this long paragraph number 377 we're
going to see a very important juncture
point where self-consciousness can get
stuck and remain stuck quite easily in a
figure of projection essentially
projection of evil of perversion as
Hagel is going to call it for caroling
on to the other on to the world in a way
to try to avoid it for it for the self
this is something that a person can get
stuck in or they can continue to
progress which is what happens in the
rest of the paragraph and leads us to
the end of this this section and into
the next dialectic so Hagel talks about
the heartthrob for the welfare of
humanity very romantic language right
the person is motivated by
sentimentality and empathy and all this
great stuff right the heartthrob for the
welfare of humanity therefore passes
into the ravings of an insane
self-conceit into the fury of
consciousness to preserve itself from
what from destruction a kind of fear why
is this well because we saw there's this
fundamental contradiction underlying the
relation between the law of the heart in
the individual and the rest of the world
the order that the world is in so he
says it does this how does it preserve
itself from destruction it does this by
expelling from itself and projecting
onto somebody or something or somebody's
else the perversion the four kiram this
twisted pneus this being unstrained
right and so he says it expels from
itself the perversion which it is itself
it still remains perversion and that's
where this is going to end in this
paragraph but it but it can tell itself
no no it's not me it's it's them and now
Hagel depicts for us oh
world that should be very familiar if
you've done much reading of
enlightenment thought or of you know
romantic thought that is is you know
closely connected with the Enlightenment
why are things so messed up well it's
because of those selfish self-centered
into domination into gluttony bastards
at the top who are screwing everybody
over including me the do-gooder who's
going to set everything right there
standing in my way and they're screwing
everybody else over to through their
universal order how does this work out
so Hagel talks about it like this the
person expels from themselves the
perversion which is in themselves
striving to look at it and express it as
something else it therefore speaks of
the universal order which is required
for any society or culture or community
to work and find meaning in it right it
speaks to the universal order as a
perversion of the law of the heart and
of its happiness so we're kind of back
where we began right there the world is
unfair the law of the heart is going to
set things straight because I know you
know I'm the one who's actually you know
motivated properly to save humanity from
whatever it needs to be saved from and
the universal order is doing the
opposite the universal order is itself a
perversion of the law of the heart and
if it's happiness now where did this
come from a perversion invented by
fanatical priests people who want to
have other people see things their way
they can't accept any sort of opposition
fanatical right maybe it doesn't have to
be priests necessarily it could become
as ours it could be the boss who needs
everyone to see things their way it
could be people on the left it could be
people on the right it could whatever
you want it to be right and gluttonous
despot he says you know people who are
this is the way Plato depicts the despot
you know in his dialogues the despot
is enthralled to their own appetites
they just want more and more and more
and I'll sort of like the corrupt Roman
emperors or these corrupt princes and
kings you know or you know revolutionary
sometimes turn into this as well so he
says fanatical priest gluttonous despots
and their minions this is sort of like
straight out of her cell there are
minions who compensate themselves for
their own degradation by degrading and
oppressing others Rousseau says you know
to answer the question well why would
anybody be you know in a position where
they're dominated by somebody else if
they don't have to be so well it's
compensated by the fact that they get to
dominate somebody lower on the
proverbial pecking order right so you
know it's okay to be somebody's valet
provided you can go kick somebody else
beneath you and and you know on and on
and on and Rousseau is probably bright
about this at least with some people
there are some people who are willing to
put up with all sorts of indignities so
long as they get to impose equal or at
least compensatory indignities upon
somebody else so this is what Rousseau
is what we sow said was going on is what
Hagel says the person motivated by the
law of the heart is is seeing and they
what happens is there's a perversion
which leads to that as he calls it the
nameless misery of diluted humanity so
this is pretty bad right we've got the
people on top and their henchmen or hunt
women imposing a order which is really
an unjust order because it's not really
Universal it just reflects the
individuality of these other people not
anything that's for the universal and it
you know land squarely on the backs of
the rest of humanity who are treated
terribly and have no say in it
whatsoever and now who gets to be the
White Knight riding in to fix things the
person of the law of the heart
so he goes on and he says in this it's
derangement consciousness declares
individuality to be the source of this
derangement and perversion whose
individuality though these guys these
bad guys there are the ones responsible
so it's not just individuality per se
it's not my individuality that's at
fault because I have the beacon of the
law of the heart within me to shine and
light my way these guys have anti
beacons darkness they just corrupt
everything make it worse so the law of
the heart not only has a kind of
equivocal status doesn't it so he goes
on and he says in this deranged been
consciousness declares individuality to
be the source of this derangement and
perversion one that is accidental and
alien it is the heart however or the
individuality of consciousness that
would be immediately Universal that
would come in and fix things whose heart
my heart right and he says here we go
that is itself the source of this
derangement and perversion the outcome
of this action is merely that its
consciousness becomes aware of this
contradiction so here's where the person
could realize oh wait a second how do I
know I'm not one of those those people
the mere fact that I don't have power
doesn't mean that I've actually managed
to be completely right be completely
straight not be perverse at all turned
in turned away so it goes on and he says
the true is where at the law of the
heart which is something merely intended
unlike the established order has not
stood the test of time the established
order you can at least say and this is
what defenders of order always do it
look this has been working for us don't
screw it up by trying to fix that
we don't know whether the person
motivated by the law of the heart is
really going to make things better or
they might make things worse think about
somebody like robes Pierre you know you
could say that he was motivated by
something like the law of the heart he
wanted to improve humanity he saw that
you know getting rid of the despot it's
getting rid of the priest was a very
important way to do that and he
unleashes a terror which consumes the
French nation and ultimately leads to
his own demise as he finds people yet
more radical than himself so this is a
big problem you can find other things
along these lines as well the true for
it is the law of the heart something
merely intended when it is tested its
overthrown so this is law what you have
reality the law of the heart wat you
have reality but that means the law is
for it reality qua valid ordinance its
own aim and essential nature but reality
that very law qua valid ordinance is on
the contrary immediately for it
something which is not valid so you got
your choice law of the heart not
realized ideal good law over here which
you actually have stood the test of time
bad evil unfair but real which are you
going to pick so he goes on and he says
similarly its own reality the heart
itself is a particular individual
consciousness is for it its essence but
its purpose is to establish that
particular individuality as an objective
being out there in the world replacing
that old order up turning it liberating
humanity getting rid of the tyrants all
those those sorts of actions so he says
thus it is not it is rather itself and
as not a particular individual that is
immediately for it its essence or its
purpose as the form of a law hence the
form of a universality which is for it
its own consciousness we've seen this
already in the previous paragraphs in so
far as my action not the action of
projection but the
that's going to fix things is a
universal producing action it is a
tattered respect no longer just my
action and eventually no longer
expresses the law of my heart but law in
general it attains this the status of
universal ordering so he goes on he says
this its notion becomes by its own
action its object so what is the heart
learn the heart learns rather that
itself below of the heart in its very
fabric is not real and its reality is an
unreality so what do we have here it's
therefore not an accidental an alien
individuality but just this particular
heart which in all its aspect is in its
own self what we see here the attempt to
displace perversion does not work comes
right back Hagel says the law of the
individual heart now realizes itself in
all of its aspects perverted and
perverting so what do we have going on
here how did it get perverted maybe by
this world order maybe it's not quite so
pure maybe it's not so untainted maybe
itself is something like the tyrant or
the fanatical priest engaging in
oppression of others you know creating
nameless misery for deluded humanity
that's a problem and that's where we
reach so we have two options we can come
to that point and we still have not
gotten through the dialectic altogether
or we can just continue projecting onto
others and stay stuck at that point in
the dialectic forever
you